>> Sean: FOX NEWS ALERT TONIGHT.
MULTIPLE PEOPLE ARE DEAD
INCLUDING AN OFFICER AT A
SUPERMARKET IN BOULDER,
COLORADO.
HERE WITH THE LATEST FROM THE
SCENE IS OUR OWN ALICIA ACUNA.
ALICIA, TERRIBLE WHAT WE'RE
HEARING.
YOU JUST HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE
AS WELL YOU WERE ATTENDING.
>> YES, GOOD EVENING, SEAN.
THE BOULDER POLICE COMMANDER
HERE TELLING US THAT YES, IN
FACT THEY DID LOSE ONE OF THEIR
OWN TONIGHT.
ONE OF THEIR OFFICERS KILLED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY WHILE
RESPONDING TO THE SHOOTING AT
THE KING SOOPER HERE IN BOULDER.
INITIALLY THEY SAID MULTIPLE
FATALITIES.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBERS KILLED IN THIS GROCERY
STORE THIS AFTERNOON.
SO THEREFORE THEY WON'T RELEASE
ANYMORE INFORMATION INCLUDING
HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT THEY
BELIEVE DIED IN THE STORE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
PROCESSING THE CRIME SCENE.
AS THE COMMANDER HERE PUT IT,
THEY'RE STILL MAKING NEW
DISCOVERIES.
WHAT WE ALSO DON'T KNOW IS WHAT
THE MOTIVE IS HERE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS ONE
SUSPECT THAT IS BEING TREATED AT
A HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW.
HE'S ALSO IN CUSTODY.
HIS IDENTITY, ANY DETAILS ABOUT
HIM NOT BEING RELEASED AT THIS
POINT.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THIS
AS THE EVEN GOES ON.
BOULDER POLICE WILL GIVE MORE
UPDATES A